this is chapter 10
on matrix multiplication so far we've
seen
well a couple of different kinds of
multiplication if you like you can think
of the inner product as a multiplication
of two vectors
we've seen matrix vector multiplication
and now we're going to step it up one
and look at matrix matrix multiplication
you can multiply two matrices
um we're going to say that has a lot of
uses
okay so uh if i have
an m by p matrix and a p
by n matrix uh the first one is a
and the second one is b and note that
the matrix a has
a number of columns that's p which is
equal to the number of
rows of b that is critical okay
i can multiply a and b
to get another matrix which i'll call c
and we're simply going to write it as a
b
so we're heavily overloading
multiplication notation
the ordinary ordinary multiplication
notation is by simply you put two things
together
right so next to each other so if i say
something like you know uh you just put
them together
we do that with matrix vector
multiplication but here it's matrix
matrix
okay now here to say what c is i have to
tell you what its entries are
um and so it's i j entry
is a sum of products of
entries of a and entries of b and here's
what they are
a sum over a i k that's walking across
the eighth row of a and i multiply those
by b k j now
here uh j is fixed and so k
is changing in my sum and i'm walking
down
the j column of b
and i can write it out that way if you
don't like the sum uh the sum notation
okay and so very roughly speaking here's
how you get
the i j entry of the product matrix you
move along
the ith row of a and you move
down the jth column of b and you're
roughly speaking take the inner product
or the you know basically take the sum
of the products of the corresponding
numbers okay so let's do an example
and by the way you may have seen this in
a previous course as well so i just want
to make sure everyone's on the same page
okay so for example here is a two
by three matrix and here is a three by
two matrix and the thing we have to
check is that the intermediary dimension
is the same so the number of co of
columns of the first matrix
is equal to the number of rows of the
second and indeed it is three is equal
to three
and the result is actually two by two
okay so before you ever multiply two
matrices
you must do perform this syntax check
just to make sure if it's a valid
product okay so this is valid
wouldn't be an example on the slides if
it weren't but okay
all right so let's actually work figure
out how to do this well
the first entry that's going to be c11
and that's obtained by going across the
first column here
and down the first sorry across the
first row here
and down the first column here and
indeed it's minus 1.5
plus 3 times 0 which is 0
plus 2. and you should get this okay so
that should be your number
uh that's right so okay um
all right let's let's let's audit
another entry how about
let's try this one okay so to get the 2
2 entry of c
we would go along the second
row of a and down the second column and
let's just check it you get 1 times
minus 1
okay that's minus 1 plus minus 1 times
minus 2
is 2 so we're up to 1 and then 0 times 0
so we're one and that's correct
okay so um by the way at this point
matrix multiplication
this is like the rules of chess it
should have no interest there's
there's no reason you should have any
interest in this yet so you have to take
me
on my word that this is actually going
to be super useful and super important
but for the moment it's just
these are just the rules this is how you
do it okay
um so there are um
we've already seen various types of
multiplication
and they're all actually uh special
cases of matrix multiplication so
here's one we saw the scalar vector
product um
and we would write it as alpha x where
alpha is a scalar and x is a vector
now it turns out that's not a special
case
of of of matrix multiplication it's got
the wrong
if the sizes are wrong alpha is like one
by one
and let's say x is n by one
right so you can see the intermediary
dimensions don't line up
so in fact however if you do scalar
multiplication with a scalar on the
right
it actually works it act and it's
exactly the same
now for some i guess this is just the
quirks of mathematical notation
people don't write a vector with a
scalar on the right
although i think what this shows you is
they should
um but nevertheless they do i mean if
someone does that
no one would think i mean they would
think it's weird but they would fully
understand what you're saying
um you could even explain this and then
they go oh cool
that's even good for you okay so
um so just mathematical notation
convention is we don't write
um a scalar vector multiplication
usually with a scalar on the right
almost always it's in the front and
that's just that's a tradition that goes
back
probably a couple hundred years by now
so that's how we do it all right
inner product is actually now it's a
perfect example of this right
so this says you have two n vectors a
and b and it says
you form the transpose and so uh a
is n by one a transpose is 1 by n
b is n by 1. sure enough the
intermediary dimensions
are the same and so you can multiply
them and the result is going to be a one
by one
one by one matrix which we interpret as
a scalar
okay or a number and it is exactly the
inner product
matrix vector multiplication that's one
so here
a is m by n let's say and
x is n by one and sure enough you can
multiply them you can think of
x as a vector sorry as a matrix and then
perform matrix vector
matrix matrix multiplication and it's
the same as matrix vector multiplication
okay um ah
we can now tell you about something
called the outer product
of two vectors so uh two vectors by the
way have any of any size it doesn't
because it always works so if i have an
m vector
a and an n vector b i can form a b
transpose now
to figure out what this means a is an m
vector so it is
m by one and b
is n by one b transpose is one
by n and sure enough the intermediary
dimension is one
and when you multi when you work out
what it is it creates a matrix which is
m by n and the entries are all products
of all possible entries of a
with b okay so that's called the outer
product
you've seen the inner product and you
can see it's they're very close
in terms of this notation right one is a
transpose b
that gives you a scalar and a b
transpose that gives you a matrix it's
called the outer product well
we'll encounter that a couple of times
probably
okay now matrix multiplication is a
bunch of properties that hold
um i'm actually not going to show them
i mean somebody has to or should
you could trust me that's an option i
suppose at this point
or you could audit one or two of these
your yourself um
so but i'll i'll go over them and say
kind of what they mean um
it's super important that you stay on
your toes with this notation to make
sure everything here works
so here i have three matrices
oh and the the the implication the
assumption generally is this is that
when i write down matrix
products of matrices like a b the
assumption is that that's
a valid product right and oh so some
people would say that they are
compatible or something like that
or it just means the intermediary
dimension is is correct
right so what i'm writing down here
whenever you see things like that
the assumption is that that everything
is correct right if i then later tell
you
a has this dimension b has system c has
then you raise a big alarm and you go
hey
you can't multiply a and b makes no
sense or something like that
so okay um so this says
this says multiply the two matrices a
and b first and then multiply by c
on the right then it turns out that's
the same
as if i multiplied the matrices b and c
and then multiplied by a on the left
and so what that means is we can write
both as the triple product abc
right because what it says is that
when you write down the product of three
matrices it doesn't matter whether you
multiply a
and b first and then c or b and c first
and then a
so that that's that that's an important
thing okay
um it distributes um so a
matrix times b plus c is equal to a b
plus ac now you have to be super duper
on your toes here
in this equation um first of all it must
be that a and that b and c have the same
size otherwise you cannot you have no
right to add them no you don't have to
write it just
means nothing if if they are not the
same size so
presumably in this line b and c have the
same size
and this is the plus that's the the
addition of matrices
okay so it says add the matrices b and c
multiplied by a on the left
over here it's different this says
multiply first a
by b then a by c and then add them so
this is also
matrix addition but it's possibly a
different size matrix
right so um okay
here's one a b quantity transpose
is is b transpose a transpose so
roughly speaking the product transpose
is the the product
in reverse order of the matrices
themselves transposed
i mean honestly it's easier just to look
at the equation okay so
it looks like it looks like this right a
very important rule um
so uh and you might not think that right
because for example
um aesthetically you might say
i don't know this this this looks
reasonable
right um and it looks reasonable uh it
is
very and deeply wrong for many reasons
um
i mean first of all it's just false but
the other thing is it's a lot of times
it doesn't make any sense
right that depending on the dimensions
of a and b
uh a transpose and b transpose always
make sense but you can't multiply them
necessarily
so this is just wrong okay um
oh here's one a times the identity is a
if i multiply on the right by an
identity matrix i get a
if i multiply on the left by an identity
matrix i get a
and by the way these two i's are of
different sizes if a is m by
n this i is n by n that identity matrix
and this i is m by m okay so here
you just get things from you get the
dimensions which are ambiguous because i
didn't say what size
i is in the two equations you get it
from the syntax of the equations
okay now here's something
super duper important um
it's very important the product a b
is not necessarily equal to product b a
actually it's worse than that
uh even if you can multiply a b there's
no reason to believe that you can
multiply
uh b a it may be incompatible okay
um but even when it does make sense
uh it's it even when a b and b
a are both valid products they are not
they need not be equal to each other now
of course in some cases they
are uh i'll give you an example uh you
know
a times i equals i
times a and a has and let's make a yeah
we'll just leave it this way a is square
in this case right so the two i's are
the same matrix of the same size
um that's true by the way
when two matrices when you multiply them
together and you get the same result
they have to be square if you get the
same result no matter which order you
you multiply them in that's called
commutative they commute it means you
can kind of put them in you can
multiply them in either order okay but
in general
that doesn't hold that's a very
important fact
okay now block matrices will work with
matrix multiplication so for example
here
first of all this would simply be the
formula for if
a b c d e f g h were numbers this would
be a two by two matrix two by two matrix
and that's a two by two matrix
and this is indeed the correct formula
for what happens when you multiply two
two by two matrices
however what's cool here is that
uh here these could be blocks so that's
a block 2x2 matrix that these are block
matrices so
a b c and d can themselves be matrices
as can e
f g and h now for all of this to make
sense
everything has to you know any matrix i
write down here when i'm
multiplying has to have the right i mean
things have to have the right dimensions
otherwise this is all well it's
meaningless right but
if if these are valid products then this
this identity holds so it says that we
can do matrix multiplication by
blocks which is actually kind of cool
one
very important thing and that goes back
to this fact uh
is you when you're messing with matrices
and writing down equations
um you have to be very
careful with the order of them so a b
is not ba so don't do don't do anything
that depends on a b b and b a
which you're used to because that's true
for numbers the product of two and three
is the product of three and two
but the product of two matrices in
reverse order when it makes sense need
not be
the same as the other one so just be
super careful about keeping the order
right so
for example in this formula up here if
a b c d e f g h were numbers
i could remove that and write ea
it would be true it would still be
correct because
ea and ae are are the same
provided that they're scalars right if
however they're matrices they're not the
same and then this what i've written
down here is just wrong
okay so you just have to be very careful
it's order
matters okay now we'll give a couple of
interpretations
and we'll we'll be using all of these
basically throughout the sequel
the rest of the course so um if you
denote let's first write out b
um in the product a b as uh columns
okay so they it's b1 b2 up to bn
right so and remember that b is going to
be p
by n and a is going to be
m by p this is a
and this is b okay so it's going to look
like that
and if i work out what a b is actually i
can do this by
block matrix multiplication so i simply
write b
as a block matrix where the blocks are
the columns
and then i just multiply out as if
these were numbers or whatever and i get
being very careful with the order
and i get a b 1 and then a b 2
and each of these is a column and so now
what you can see
is if one interpretation of a matrix a
times a matrix b
is it is simply it works column by
column it just says
take the matrix b multiply every column
of b
by a and then rearrange them into a
matrix so you could think of it as some
people think of a b
as a batch multiply of a times all the
columns of b
so that's one way people think of it
as an example we can represent multiple
sets of linear equations
with a very compact notation so
remember that a system of linear
equations look like looks like a
x equals b that's a system of linear
equations um
if this is uh if there's if a is m by n
this is m equations in the n variables
which is
x um b has size m here
uh it has dimension n okay but now
suppose we have
multiple uh linear equations but
with the same coefficient matrix a but
with different right hand sides bi
well we can write that in super compact
notation this way
and now i have basically a system of
linear equations
x is a matrix and it literally means
that its columns are the different
are the different x's and b's of the
different b so so that's
by the way this is going to be important
later in the course but that this is
kind of the idea so it's super compact
notation
if you write stuff out this way okay
another very useful interpretation for
us is going to be the inner product
interpretation so as you know to
calculate an entry of the product
you go along the row of a if it's a
times b
you go along a certain row of a and down
a certain column but b
very roughly speaking you're taking the
inner product of a row of a
and a column of b well we can write it
out this way
we can say that a b is the following
matrix it's it's the first
uh row of a times i should say
the the first column of b that's a1
transpose times b1
and so on and so what it is is you could
think of this as a matrix product
gives you all the inner products of the
rows of a
and the columns of b and then arranged
into a matrix so that's a perfectly good
way
to think about matrix uh multiplication
it's useful
actually all these different ways
they're not very hard to work out
uh they're all related and and they're
all useful in different uh settings
so here's a matrix that's going to come
up uh pretty often in
in the sequel it's called the gram
matrix that's the name of a grandma's
name of a mathematician
from the 19th century um so
let's let a uh be an m by n matrix and
its columns are a one through a
n and each of those is an m vector
okay well the gram matrix is simply this
boy
and it's a very compact notation it's g
equals
a transpose a a transpose a that's
something you're going to be seeing a
lot of to be honest so
get used to it but it's got a beautiful
interpretation
so the entries of a transpose are
exactly the following
they are the first entry is a1 transpose
a1
but you know what that is that's
actually the norm squared of a1 okay
so the one
two entry is the inner product of
the first and second column okay
by the way the two one entry is the
inner product of the set
of the it's the inner product of the
second column of the first but you know
that inner product does commute
so these are the same number and what
that says is
the matrix g is a symmetric matrix right
it which means
that if you transpose it you get back
the same matrix
it means that it's i j entry and it's j
i entry are the same
okay so anyway this is the gram matrix
it's a super useful
um we can also use super fancy um we can
use
matrix uh matrix arguments to show
that g is symmetric so if i say that
if i want to know what is g transpose
well that's a
transpose a transpose okay
but that's the product of two matrices
and then transposed but we know what
that is
that's simply the transpose of the
second matrix and then times the
transpose of the first matrix so this is
equal to
a transpose times a transpose transpose
but wait a minute a transpose transpose
is a
if i transpose a matrix twice i get back
the matrix so this is actually
a transpose a hey but that's g
and this string of equality says that g
transpose is g that means g is symmetric
okay um so here's something you can do
uh with the gram matrix that it gives
you a
very compact way to describe a concept
that we already have
it's a transpose a equals i super
interesting it means that if you look at
this
if you look at this matrix here it's
ones on the diagonal and zero off
let's see what that means well if a
transpo if a1 transpose a1 is one
that means the length of the norm of a1
is one same for a2
and so what it says is the diagonal of
the gram matrix
is equal to they're all ones provided
uh all of the columns of a have the same
norm which is one
okay so that's normalized but now let's
look at off diagonal entry
if if this is i it means the off
diagonal entries are zero so that says
that a1 transpose a2 is zero
that means that a1 and a2 are orthogonal
but so are a1 and a3 and a1 and a4 and
so on
and so basically the super compact
equation a transpose a
equals i is a way to say that the
columns of a
are orthonormal they each have uh norm
one
and uh different columns are orthogonal
they have an inner product of zero okay
so this is the gram
matrix
let me say a little bit about the
complexity of multiplying two matrices
um actually this is a super interesting
topic i might say a little bit about it
in a minute but
uh so the basic way is here
is a is m by
p and then b is p by n
okay so now to get an entry
and every entry of c is basically an
inner product
uh so and what i'm gonna do is uh
you know that the number of flops to
calculate a p long inner product is
actually two p minus one but we skip the
minus one and no one pays any attention
it's just 2p
um and so c you have to get all the
entries of c
c is going to end up being m by n so
i have to do for all the entries i have
to calculate inner product and i get two
m and p flops so basically the total
number of flops required to multiply
two matrices is the product of their
dimensions um
well the intermediary dimensions which
have to match on the two matrices
um have to be the same and so it's the
product of the three numbers
that's it so for example if i were to
multiply two thousand by thousand
matrices
that requires two billion flops right so
um by the way this is a lot right i mean
these are big i mean if you think about
it these are very big like if someone
says what's a thousand by thousand
matrix you'd say
oh it's a rectangular array of one
million numbers it's a lot at least to a
person it's a whole lot
right and then you multiply the two
together and you say that would require
two
billion floating point operations so if
you had to do this by hand or whether
you know or with a slide rule or an
abacus it's going to take you a long
time
so on my laptop which is way old
now i can do this in about .1
seconds okay so that's
crazy what i just said and actually it's
a very important you know
all the math we're doing was just as
true
and just as interesting in 1830 or 1880
or something like that or 1950.
this is what you didn't have in 1950 was
the ability
to actually do these count do the
calculations that we're talking about in
this course
at truly stunning speeds
um i mean so this is just stunning so i
guarantee on your homework you will
one of your homework problems will be to
multiply two thousand by thousand
matrices and then have a moment of quiet
to sit there and appreciate
how like awesome that is
that the little processor in your laptop
or whatever you're doing this on for
that matter you can do this on a phone
okay but the point is to sit there and
have a moment of silence to just
recognize
how awesome it is that two billion
floating point operations were just
carried out for you in about a tenth of
a second